it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week Matt Stone and Trey Parker
at a turn-based RPG to their long list
of amazing creations with south park the
stick of truth from the perilous
battlegrounds 4th grade playground a
young hero will rise destined to become
South Park Savior and with the help of
Stan Kyle Cartman and Kenny a new friend
will rise up the social ladder and some
cool though probably never is coolest
butters you want to do any method a
method you are customize your character
to play as one of four different classes
including fighter nage the flight and
even June become the silent protagonist
douchebag march forth welcome to the KKK
douchebag did you you probably can also
handle our finest also this week an
unexpected guest stops by and changes
everything in the second episode of the
walking dead season 2 Clementine should
know better than to let strangers into
the house I need an adult I needed
adults the new guy scares the housemates
so much they choose to leave and look
for a new shelter elsewhere leaving them
open to zombie attacks break out your
trusty hammer March for also this week
we get a different kind of first-person
adventure that blurs the line between
two and three dimensions as well as
reality and the supernatural with year
walk on PC venture out into the dark
woods were strange creatures roam on a
Vision Quest set in 19th century Sweden
solve cryptic puzzles and discover if
your loved one will ever love you back
the highly praised game started out on
iOS but is now able to haunt your dreams
on the PC cannot on the sea is super
creepy journey starts march six
and finally we get a new version of the
popular top-down shoot-'em-up dead
nation apocalypse addition the zombie
exploding game will be available on the
playstation store for about fifteen
dollars if your PlayStation Plus member
is absolutely free this game comes from
the same developer of the super startup
series and resogun so you're going to
want to pick this up I mean come on it's
free can't argue free speaking of free
gamespot is giving away four copies of
South Park's the stick of truth this
Tuesday on the lobby go to gamespot com
and check out this week's episode of the
lobby to try and get yours for further
details visit gamespot's new releases
page release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week